why are fake allies or fake foes and
stories so important these characters
are what I call the in-between
characters of a story because we have on
one side the hero and the heroes allies
on the other side we have the main
opponent and any secondary opponents
that you may have in the story these are
clear characters in opposition but one
of the keys to plot if not the key to
blog is surprise revealed we want to not
only surprise the hero over the course
of the story we want to surprise the
audience that's essentially what plot is
know the question is well how do we get
reveals how do we get surprises we give
them a lot of different ways but one of
the most important ways is with these
in-between characters character who
appears to be an ally that is real an
opponent somebody who appears to be an
opponent but it's really an element
every time the audience sees that
somebody they thought was one in turns
out to be another well that's a reveal
that's a plot beat and that's where the
audience goes oh yes that was really
great thank you
that's the power of plot and these
characters are one of the main ways that
we get these surprises for the audience
now to see the value of this character
take a look at the Harry Potter stories
and of course the most obvious example
of this is Snape who switches back and
forth between a parent ally and a parent
opponent for seven books right that's
how useful this character this type of
character is because every time he
switches we surprise the audience she
was able to see
that source of plot for seven full books
this is one of the ways that we know
that she's a master storytellers just
that technical alone she of course many
many others that she was used but that's
one of the most important what is the
double reversal double reversal is a
very advanced technique where that by
the way is not seen in most stories
double reversal occurs when not only the
hero but the main opponent learn
something at the end now when it's done
properly and by the way the place where
we see this technique used most often is
in love stories because the love stories
this is a genre that is designed from
the very beginning to end with a double
reversal where both hero and lover learn
and change at the end there's we have
two people having character change not
just that not just one know when it's
done properly worse like this we have a
hero who learns from the opponent in
growth we have an opponent who learns
from the hero and grows and it's the
blending of the best of both characters
that is then the author's view of the
right way to live it is that's the
author's theme what they're trying to
get across to the audience but they're
doing it through two characters instead
of just one I say it's a very advanced
technique you don't usually see it
because in order to have this technique
you have to have an opponent who is
capable of learning and unfortunately
most opponents are not and that's a
problem of craft where they did not
design the opponent in such a way to
more than just a villain
you